o elegeria às vezes na internet com 17
anos e eu tenho de fato anos o que faz
dele um android entre integrantes da
geração de vozes às vezes vocês conhecem
os jovens mudar ea gente tem dinheiro no
mundo ea gente não pode trabalhar no
escritório porque a gente fica presente
quando se torna se até então se regra ea
gente tem poder trabalhar jones
exigências e aí ano passado finalmente
por mês não é e nem os ônibus estão
desesperados por uma entrega e
completado de verdade só que tava
complicado achar um emprego assim até
porque não teria de jenin achando
pecuniário e aí alguns dos vídeos o que
quer fazer as coisas que a gente acha
ideal mas a gente tem os seus pilotos
imagina você vê que a gente acha que é
genial e não acho genial vai lidar com
essa rejeição não tem como os vídeos
porque eu queria vencer isso
ele se inscreveu no canal mesmo assim
nenhum tipo de floro assim como a selva
e recomeçando começaram a sentir o canal
também e é enorme diz que 10 mil
e aí eles chover em um canal
depois de ter passado horas e horas a
menina contando histórias terríveis que
fazer com ela em um livro aquelas
histórias porque entende toda sorte que
eu tive até que fala de um dia pra ela e
falou tiro fatal no vermelho com uma
curta aí né
isso porque eu fui no facebook em 2010 e
eu nem é seja vender o produzido na
china escolhe além daquelas histórias e
chorar de olhar o perfil daquelas que
deus me olhar eu fiquei investirá e
fiquei muito admirado pelas histórias e
comecei a estar pop crunch
assim nasceu o vídeo não tinha antes de
se colocar qualquer coisa
assim 15 mil visualizações em vídeo e aí
nesse dia que eu coloquei esse vídeo
sobre relacionamentos abusivos teve mais
40 anos o primeiro dia ou seja um
sucesso né e diferente porque no 26
compartilhar todo facebook vai lá e todo
mundo falava no meio e aí depois eu
parei mais dois segundos para pensar eu
falei 'não não é bom ter feito sucesso
porque significa que ilegal é isso mesmo
e aí o que permite coisas e aí eu
comecei a receber mensagens de email
facebook de pessoas falam de justiça à
cabeça testou jorge wilson sons - igor
assim ou seja cinco anos temos aí há
cinco anos não se ajudando e até o posto
está lá
judite de sousa não é produzir diesel
todos os ângulos maneira é muito boa até
fechar um dia no metrô em uma mocinha e
palha e como essa melhora se chorando
porque tinha juntado uma grande amiga
dela a pedir vose
e aí se você for olhar o canal na
verdade uma grande bagunça super de
chato produção mas ele gerará uma
mudança na vida delas e aí isso né
importante sobre o disse que eu não
posso não é porque com ele
então eu vou ele na rua eu estou ótimo
obrigada eu tenho um grupo que se
conheceu no canal ele esfriar um pouco e
eles não só
quando a relação deles chama louca e é
isso que o assunto se grito que você
consegue tocar na mídia
elas vivem e itália acontece com elas e
um jovem cheio de um todo inclusive
comigo e aí supernormal coisas mais
naturais com um super fã do rio
elas começam a mandar e mail agradecendo
telas mas eu falo da perspectiva
denuncia que tem vontade no mundo e aí
porque completa
não só segurança ele não fala ruim amiga
penso sobre feliz aqui
nesse vídeo e eu acho isso acontece
porque a gente as nossas chances de
receber ordem de encaminha contando o
que sabe falar isso vai formando errado
daí fazer de outro jeito esse jeito que
eu estou aqui eu sei que hoje em dia e
agora já tem mais de 100 mil pessoas
nesse meu barzinho e eu converso com
elas
hoje em dia já ligado